It remains unclear how and when Muammar Gadhafi died Thursday.
The body ultimately ended up in cold storage...
...a day after national transitional forces reportedly first captured him alive.
As word continued to spread around the world of Gadhafi's demise,...
...many thought the longtime leader got what he deserved.
They should kill and torture him like he did to them.
It should be his destiny like he tortured his own people.
But Tom Porteous with Human Rights Watch sees the outcome of Gadhafi's death differently.
It's not really a question about what he deserved.
It's a question about the path that the new Libya wants to take.
Libyan officials say that Gadhafi died while being transported...
...after being plucked from a drainage pipe,...
...but reports and footage cast doubts...
... showing Gadhafi was more likely killed in the chaos during his capture.
Porteous says that there needs to be an investigation.
And it's absolutely essential that the new authorities send a very strong signal...
...that they intend to take the path of building a new Libya...
...based on human rights and respect for the rule of law.
And this is a chance to do so.
He says that the people who took up arms against Gadhafi said they were doing it...
...in part to build a new Libya based on pluralism...
...and a respect for human rights and the rule of law.
If the interim government fails to investigate, Porteous says it runs the danger...
...that the new Libya will be acting similar to the old.
Sean Maroney, VOA News, Washington.